[Music]
i want to share with you all three
versions of an exercise that i recently
came up with going from beginner
intermediate
[Music]
and advanced
i quite like this exercise because it
has a blend of a sort of mysterious
sound and also a heroic quality and when
i'm practicing this i also get to work a
little more on my left hand than my
right hand which i always find is a
great thing because by default i notice
myself over practicing the right hand
and not paying attention to the left
hand
all of these exercises are alternating
between minor and major triads i'll be
going more into the details behind each
exercise after the demonstrations so
let's first go into each exercise
demonstrated in six different
transpositions
[Music]
for those of you interested in the
theory behind the chord progression it's
relatively simple we're first starting
in a minor
with a minor one chord so this is an a
minor triad
going to
a major five
so this is
e major
and here is what's slightly different
instead of playing a
major three chord which would be the
most common thing
i'm changing that to
a minor three so c minor
and
then i'm going to a g major chord you
can consider it a major seven chord
within a minor still
or you can look at it as the five chord
of the c minor chord
or you can also look at it as a minor
four
which is slightly altered going to
a major one
the last major triad
turns into a minor triad
and this is the beginning of the next
transposition
for version one i first recommend
playing all of these three notes of each
triad together first
hand separately then break it up so
you're first playing the bottom note
then the middle note
then the top note
same for the next chord
[Music]
take note of the fact that
after the first triad we're repeating
that top note
going from the thumb to the fifth finger
[Music]
and to get that to be smooth you really
don't need to
do much other than bring these two
fingers together
so bring it together
instead of
trying to
switch over if that makes sense
[Music]
after this first iteration
[Music]
the second version uses four notes in
the left hand per chord instead of three
here are the chords a minor
[Music]
e major
[Music]
c minor
[Music]
g major
so it is basically a triad
plus an octave on top
or surrounding it
and this is broken up
like so
so this third
note here
which is the top of the triad
is repeated
[Music]
now something that i noticed just now is
that in the right hand i tend to use
mostly 5432 i don't
[Music]
always end with a thumb another
variation that would help you practice
and learn this
is to break it up
into two chords
[Music]
so there are a lot of variations that
you can play around with
[Music]
in version 3 i am expanding each chord
so that it is much wider
i might get used to that pattern first
and then just roll the tenths
[Music]
and then work on those repeated notes
i would just stop after the repeat so
after one two
until that's comfortable
i would also practice in tempo
just two chords at a time
then moving on
[Music]
i need to make a note about the rhythm
which i consider to be 10 16 rather than
5 8 because
this is really divided into two halves
one
two
one
two
and if you count it in five that might
be confusing
all right so i hope you all can try at
least one or two or all three of these
versions let me know how it goes down in
the comments thank you so much for
watching and a special thank you to my
patrons over at patreon the bonus
material patrons will receive a link to
the pdf to these exercises
among other things
and i will see you all in the next video